depuis le début' cette crise on peut
dire que les artistes très durement
touchés eux aussi nous propose des
grands moments de d'espoir et de bonheur
et on les fait déjà cette émission qu'on
leur fait ce soir avec martha wainwright
qui sentait tout à l'heure sur son
balcon 120 conquête une ouverture sur le
monde au fond un grand grand moment pour
parler lancé sa voix au loin la projeter
pour nous inspirer à l'interpréter
leonard cohen peut l'interpréter du joe
dassin bonsoir martha wainwright
alors qu'est-ce que vous ça vous apporte
comme expérience que de dettes sur votre
balcon tous les mardis d'avis notamment
19h et de chanter de chanter
larry cohen ne chantait joe dassin d'eau
on a fait une chanson de venir y en a
mais ça ça me rappelle que je suis aussi
dans tout ça et ça fait tellement du
bien de chanter pour moi mais aussi
l'idée derrière cette concept c'est
qu'un échantillon ensemble alors fait je
peux pas si c'est quelqu'un d'entier
notre artiste khalid une idée que on
chante la chanson de leonard sûrement
merial est que j'invite tout le monde à
montréal
et peut-être dans le monde aussi de
venir chanter sur leur barque au balcon
avec moi le refrain alors c'est vraiment
pour 1 voix pour montrer le pouvoir et
la beauté de la musique le chant pouvoir
montrer de la musique quel regard portez
vous comment vous la vivez vous cette
crise même s'ils essaient ainsi
tellement il ya tellement d'aspects
également comme comme mère alors mes
enfants sont à la maison avec moi sans
alors ça il ya cet élément moi aussi je
viens juste d'ouvrir un timor café à
salles de spectacles à montréal alors ça
ça a été vraiment vraiment frappé par
cette crise
ah mais aussi comme artiste j'ai perdu
beaucoup d'emplois beaucoup de la
prestation était à caen cela alors
c'était vraiment en plusieurs dans
plusieurs façons et certainement j'ai
peur pour ma famille j'ai de la famille
partout aussi à new york san francisco
et en flore et en france aussi la
famille alors c'est vraiment le tout et
je pense que c'est qu'est-ce qu'il ya
des gens vivent tout le monde ouais ça
touche tous les aspects dans tous les
esprits même un isolement on est tous
unis dans la même bataille contre un
virus
vous avez choisi une chanson de richard
desjardins laquelle est un oiseau cette
chanson pour pour vous et merci merci à
vous merci
[Musique]
les prairies l âme dans les eaux noires
et des chasseurs
[Musique]
duke là
l'eau lisieux
[Musique]
de fer contre le
l'uci
au rayon
[Musique]
sony dit
m
[Musique]
tu vois